Dog the Bounty Hunter's daughter is
shooting down rumors that he went on a
date following the death of her mom Beth
Chapman the only person who really liked
knew him like the back of his hand was
mom
Duane Chapman was snapped having dinner
with a woman at an Italian restaurant
over the weekend in LA leading some fans
to think he was on a date we have
noticed that people kind of like to see
what goes on maybe behind the scenes but
when the fan speculation started Bonnie
took to her insta story to shut down the
gossip explaining that the woman in
question is actually someone dog works
with she wrote quote pissed on my
father's behalf that he can't go on a
business dinner without someone
speculating he's on a date leave our
family alone please leave my father
alone let him try to continue our
business and peace but you get used to
the cameras after so long that we've
we've gotten used to him sometimes you
forget that they're there a source tells
ET that there were actually eight people
at the business dinner including crew
members from the family's TV show dogs
most wanted adding that the woman in the
pic is a good friend of Duane and Beth
quote she's known the family for years
this is not some secret hookup you kind
of try to remember you're celebrating
the life but right now we're mourning
the death so it's not good Beth died in
June after losing her battle with cancer
shortly after Duane opened up to et
about his loss I haven't gotten past the
place where I'm still putting a pillow
where she was and covering it up and
then I wake up bill likes ear and it
doesn't register in any juror I'm still
there he also noted that Beth didn't
want him to date anybody else for two
three years she knew this might happen
so she would say
who's gonna sit next to you and I said
no one
Big Daddy you better that let another
girl take my place I said I hold et also
spoke with Bonnie who talked about what
she learned from her late mother I'm
definitely gonna take away how
determined and how passionate she was I
I started to see myself kind of blossom
into a mini Beth uh you know and I'm
really glad that I could take away her
ferocity and take just take so much away
from her and you know I feel like I'm
I'm so blessed to have her in my life